اتهمت ايران اسرائيل بالوقوف وراءه هجوم
استهدف منشاه عسكريه بمسيرات في اصفهان
وصفته طهران بالفاشل في المقابل امتنعت
اسرائيل عن التعقيب على تقارير غربيه تؤكد
طلوعها في الهجوم مؤكده على لسان وزير
خارجيتها خلال استقباله نظيره الامريكيه
انتن بلانكن على النضال المشترك ضد
البرنامج النووي الايراني
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات في اي سياق اقليميه
ودوليا جاء الهجوم على منشاه عسكريه في
اصفهان وما دلالات تدل على اسرائيل فيه
وما الاعتبارات الداخليه والخارجيه التي
تدفع حكومه نتنياهو لتنفيذه في هذا
التوقيت على اي نحو استقبل الظهران
الرساله من وراء الهجوم وما هي ردود الفعل
المحتمله بعد ان تثبت التحقيقات وقوفه
الابيب وراءه وكيف يبدو الموقف الامريكي
من هذا المشهد في الوقت الذي يزور فيه
بلينكن المنطقه داعيا الى خفض العنف
وتثبيت الاستقرار فيها وما مدى تاثير هذا
الهجوم على الجهود الراميه لاحياء مفاوضات
الملف النووي الايراني بين طهران
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لطهران الصوره توضح في ما يتعلق
بالهجوم الذي وصفته في البدايه بالغامض
على منشاه متابعه للجيش الايراني في
اصفهان انها تل ابيب من يقف وراء الهجوم
بحسب المؤشرات التي تستمر التحقيقات في
فحصها وصولا الى اليقين الكامل بين ان
قاده اسرائيل وجريا على عاده قديمه
يمتنعون عن تاكيد او نفي ما تقوله
التقارير من انها طالعه في الهجوم وبدلا
عن ذلك تنكبوا اسرائيل على الاستثمار في
تقارب وجهات النظر مع واشنطن بشان الملف
النووي الايرانيه رغبه في الدفع بها نحو
التطابق الكامل دبلوماسيه
عسكريه وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الذي حل
في اسرائيل زائرا قبل التوجه الى رام الله
في زوجته قال انه اتفق مع رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو على انه لا
يمكن الايران ان تمتلك سلاح النوويه قال
من ناحيته سياستنا تتمثل في ان نمنع ايران
من الحصول على سلاح النوويه
وسنقوم بكل ما في وسعنا لتحقيق ذلك
تصريحات اطلقت في ظل اجواء التصعيد في
المنطقه فقد اكد مسؤول ايراني ان اسرائيل
تعرف جيدا انها ستتلقى الرد وان من يلعب
بالنار سيكون اول من يحترق في حال اشعال
حرب اقليميه
وكانت وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه قد تحدثت في
وقت سابق عن هجوم وصفته بالغامض استهدف
مصنعا عسكريا في محافظه اصفهان وسط البلاد
وتبين لاحقا انه نفذ بثلاث طائرات مسيره
صغيره كانت محمله بقنا بلاصه صغيره اطلقت
اثناء الهجوم
[موسيقى]
في هذا الموضوع معنا من طهران محمد مهدي
شريعه الدبلوماسيه الايراني
الحقيقه اعتقد ان السياق الاهم هو
القرار الذي اتخذته الحكومه الايرانيه
بتزويد روسيا بالاسلحه في حربها في
اوكرانيا الى حد علمي يبدو ان المنشاه
التي تعرضت الهجوم مرتبطه بعمليه تصنيع
طائرات المسيره اذا ما صح هذا التقدير
ربما يكون ذلك من بين الجهود الائله الى
منع ايران من تزويد روسيا بالاسلحه
وبالتالي لم نرى هجوما على منشاه نوويه
هذا واضح للغايه ولكن يبدو ان هذا الهجوم
يرتبط بالطائرات المسيره وطبعا اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ودول اخرى
غاضبه
من ايران لانها زودت روسيا بالاسلحه في
حربها في اوكرانيا
اسرائيل في الوقت الذي تقول فيه انها ان
ال ال التحقيقات ما زالت
تستكمل اليس لهذا قد يكون النتيجه خطيره
ويكون مؤشر خطير رغم ان التحقيقات لمكتمل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
مساء الخير اولا لا حاجه يعني انا اتصور
انه لا حاجه للتحقيقات من الذي يمكن ان
يقوم بهذه العمليه هل مثلا دول الجوار
الحلفاء الدول الصديقه قوى محور المقاومه
لا بالتاكيد لا يمكن ان همم يعني ان تكون
هذه العمليه قد صدرت الا من دوله من دول
الاعداء وهما الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والكيان الصهيوني لذلك من الطبيعي يعني
يقوم الكائن الصهيوني بهذه العمليه وتصور
الامر ليس بحاجه الى اثباتات او تحقيقات
لا هيك عن ان الاعلام الصهيوني وعن ان بعض
المسؤولين او المقربين من المسؤولين همم
الصهاينه قد اقروا واعترف بذلك بالامس
يديكم مثلا همم قال بكل وضوح ان ان
العمليه قام بها الكيان الصهيونيه طبعا
هذا لا يمكن ان الا بضوء اخضر من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لذلك
اصبع الاتهام مواجهه اصابع الاتهام مواجهه
الى اولا الكيان الصهيوني وثانيا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كدعم لهذا الكيان
وجهه توافق او تعطي الضوء الاخضر للقيام
بها عمليه
هل ياتي هذا بتنسيق امريكي اسرائيلي
ودائما هناك حديث عن تنسيق ولكن هل كانت
تنسيق برايك في هذه المره ام ان بنيامين
نتنياهو استبق همم الجميع همم برساله ربما
يوجهها لهذا الطرف اوضح ذلك
سوفيتي
للغايه في هذه القضيه بالتحديد لست متاكدا
هناك بعض الهجمات الاسرائيليه التي
استهدفت ايران والتي لم تنسق مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اعربت عن اعتراضها لاسرائيل
بشان تلك الهجمات في هذا الهجوم بالتحديد
انا لا اعرف ما اذا كانت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قد اعطت الضوء الاخضر لاسرائيل
اذا ما كان الهجوم قد استهدف منشئه لتصنيع
الطائرات المسيره اذا ربما يكون من
المنطقي ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تم
التشاور معها ودعمت هذا الهجوم لتصعيب
المهمه على ايران كي تزود روسيا بالاسلحه
في حربها في اوكرانيا لانه هو بكل تاكيد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تعارض امداد
روسيا باي اسلحه ولكنني لست متاكده
والحكومه الامريكيه حتى اللحظه الراهنه
وقد اصرت ان الهجوم من اسرائيل وليس
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكنها لم تقم
باي تصريحا سواء كان ذلك بشكل علني او
بشكل سري بانها على علم بهذا الهجوم قبل
حدوثه ايضا اسرائيل لم تفصح عن موقفها حتى
الان دكتور او سيد شريعه مداريه ولكن في
كل الاحوال هذه ليست اي اول مره اذا ما
اعتمدنا ما تقوله وتقارير الاعلاميه فما
الذي يمكن يعني ما هي الدلاله همم لهذا
النوع من الهجوم همم قادما من حكومه
نتنياهو وما الذي يمكن ان يكون التالي
بالنسبه لهم
اول من هذا ليس امرا جديدا يعني الحرب
الخفيه او المعلنه بين الطرفين مستمره
طبعا
انا اتصور انه الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه لا تريد ان تخوض حربا في هذه
الظروف وايضا الكيان الصهيوني يعرف
ما هي النتائج اي حرب محتمله لذلك يقوم
بعمليات من من هذا انه اما بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه اولا التنسيق
الامني خاصه في
همم ايام او الاشهر الفتره الاخيره همم
وجود بلينكن اليوم في همم
فلسطين المحتله ودوله الكيان الصهيوني
تصريح همم المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
باستراتيجيات مشتركه او او همم مصير مشترك
بين الطرفين الكيان الصهيوني صمت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه امام كل ما حصل همم
وبشكل العام العلاقات الاستراتيجيه
الموجوده بين الكيان الصهيوني بين والاهلي
المتحده الامريكيه توجه اصابع الاتهام
بشكل واضح الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ان اعترفت بذلك او لا او لم تعترف النقطه
الثالثه التي اود ان اقول لها هذه العمليه
لم تكن عمليه يعني همم لها تاثير او نتائج
لم تكن هناك خسائر لا به المباني ولا
بالمعدات ولا بالارواح والمنشئه التي تم
الهجوم عليها ليست كما قال ضيفك الامريكي
منشا ل همم صناعه المسايرات
وايضا بالاضافه الى ذلك همم ما هي علاقه
الكيان الصهيوني ب همم احيانا بما يقال عن
همم التبادل العسكري بين ايران وبين همم
روسيا بغض النظر عن حقيقه ما يقال هل هو
صحيح او لا لكن حتى لو فرضنا جدلا ان كل
ما يقال صحيح ما هي علاقه الكيان الصهيوني
ذلك على هذه الثانيه فاذا الا اذا قلنا
الا اذا قلنا ان ذلك يرتبط بالجهات
الغربيه وبدل الاوروبيه وبالولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يعني ايضا في هذا
الادعاء بالتحديد دلاله واضحه على تورط
الولايات المتحده الامريكاني سناتي على
موضوع روسيا ولكن دكتور سيمو بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده هي بالفعل يعني نقت
بنفسها عن هذا ال- همم الهجوم
وساخذ طبعا همم اجابه من همم سيد بتاعه
مداري ولكن اريد ان اسالك في يعني ما ما
هو الرد الذي يمكن ان تتوقعه من ايران على
هذا الهجوم وفي اي اتجاه
في الماضي كما اشار الضيف من ايران شاهدنا
سلسله من الهجمات بين الطرفين بين اسرائيل
وايران وبالتالي هذا النزاع السري الخفي
مستمر لسنوات طويله طبعا هو لم يبدا مع
رئيس مجلس الوزراء نتنياهو وبالتالي يعتقد
انه من المرجح للغايه ان تختار الحكومه
الايرانيه ان ترد بطريقه او باخرى قد يكون
الرد استهداف اهداف اسرائليه بشكل مباشر
او باستهداف القوات الامريكيه في سوريا او
في العراق وبالتالي يعتقدوا ان هذا قد
يؤدي الى اطلاق حلقه جديده من الهجوم
والهجوم المضاد بين اسرائيل وايران
والولايات المتحده وايران
سيد شريعه مداري اريد ربما اجابه منك
عندما يقول مسؤول ايراني انه سوف يكون
هناك رد وانه ليس اول رد ما الذي يمكن
لايران ان تفعله في الرد على هجوم تم على
ارضها
انا اعبر عن رايي الشخصي طبعا ايران لها
مشروع يعني كل ما يمكن ان تقول لن تستفز
بهذا النوع من العمليات انما تطبق مشروعها
المتكامل في المنطقه بعد بنائها للقوه
وبناء محور المقاومه وكل ما حصل في هذه
المنطقه ولا اريد ان اتطرق اليها هذه
النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه في اي رد
على عمليه ما او القيام باي عمليه همم ضد
الكيان الصهيوني هناك مجموعه من
الاعتبارات منها اعتبارات ترتبط بالقوى
الاقليميه والدوليه وايران من دون تاخذ كل
هذه الاعتبارات
بالاعتبار النقطه الثالثه انه كما قلنا
سابقا ان هذه الحرب او هذه العمليه لم تكن
جديده من نوعها الحرب مستمر بين الطرفين
واتصور همم
الذي يعني سيواجه الكيان الصهيوني في هذه
المرحله هي القوى الحنيفه لايران وليست
همم ايران اذا كانت ايران اذا همم اخطا
الكيان الصهيوني في يعني القيام بهجوم على
ايران او اذا بدا
اي عمليه ربما تؤدي الى اا عمليات عسكريه
متبادله فاتصور ان الكيان الصهيوني سيكون
هو الخاسر الكفيل
بالرد على مثل هذه العمليات همم ليست
ايران بالضروره وانما ربما تكون قوى
المقاومه او حتى القوه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في الداخل الفلسطيني اما اذا
كانت ايران ستكون الحق طيب نعم سيد سيد
يعني همم الان هذا يتزامن مع زياره
المنطقه وهو يدعو الى تهدئه في هذه
المنطقه ما الذي يمكن ان نفهمه من الموقف
الامريكي هل هناك تطابق مع الموقف
الاسرائيلي ام همم ان هذا يصلي الضوء على
اختلاف ما بين وجهتي النظر همم فرص احياء
الملف النووي الايراني المباحثات في هذا
الشيء مره اخرى مثلا الى اي ماده هناك
تباين او تطابق بين موقفين الامريكي
اسرائيل
الى الاتفاق النووي المعروف بخطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه ان اداره بايدن ترى انه
لمصلحتها ان تعود الاطراف الى خطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه وتم التفاوض بشان اتفاق
في فصل الصيف لاحياء الاتفاق النووي ولكن
لسوء الحظ ايران لم تقبل هذا الاتفاق رفضت
المسوده واضافت شروطه اسرائيل تعارض احياء
خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه وبالتالي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ليس لديها نفس
النظره بنسبه الى الاتفاق النووي مثل
اسرائيل ولكن هذا الاختلاف في هذه المرحله
بالتحديد لا يهم كثيرا لان ايران غير
مستعده للقبول باتفاقا لاحياء خطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه في عام 2015 وفي غيابه
اتفاق وفي غياب الدبلوماسيه هناك
وافعال المستوى الاسرائيلي والامريكي بان
تقرر ايران في مرحله ما بان تقترب اكثر
فاكثر من القدرات النوويه على سبيل المثال
انتاج
الاسلحه بتخصيب رانيوم 90% او
الاستمرار بعمليه التقصير بمستويات اعلى
ايران لم تقم بذلك اعتقد انه جزئيا ايران
تعرف ما هي المخاطر التي تتضمنها هكذا
عمليه ولكن اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
تحاولان ان تاشرا الى ايران بانه اذا ما
اتخذت اي خطوات في هذا الاتجاه هذا من
شانه ان يرفع من خطر نشوب النزاع وفي
الاسبوع الماضي شاهدنا مناورات عسكريه
واسعه نطاق بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهي الاكبر في التاريخ واعتقد
انها كانت رساله واضحه جدا باتجاه طهران
كي لا تتخذ خطوات اضافيه اتجاه السلاح
السيد شريعه مداري هل هكذا همم تفهم
مطهران الامر همم في في ضل ان هناك تطابق
بين تصريحات بلنكن وهمم نتنياهو او او كيف
تفهمه ولكن قبل ذلك همم دعنا نلقي نظره
على التفاعلات الدوليه بشان الهجوم على
منشاه اصفهان العسكريه ادانت الخارجيه
الروسيه الهجوم وحذرت مما وصفتها
بالتصرفات الاستفزازيه التي قد تثير
تصعيدا في وضع ملتهب بالفعل موسكو اضافه
ان مثل هذه تصرفات المدمره قد تكون لها
تبعات غير متوقعه على السلام والاستقرار
في الشرق الاوسط وفي سياق متصل قال
المتحدث باسم الكربلاند المتريكو انه ليس
بوسع المرء سوى ان يدين مثل هذه التصرفات
الموجهه ضد الدوله
البعد الروسي هذا تحدثت عنه لكن سريعه
مدارس همم كان هناك اتفاق بين نتنياهو في
التصريح تطابق في هذه التصريحات بمنع
ايران من الحصول على سلاح نووي ولكن لم
يشروا الى كيف سيفعلون ذلك ما الذي
تفهمونه انتم او الذي تفهمه السلطه في
طهره
اولا اسمح لي ان اذكر بعض النقاط يعني لا
شك هناك تباين باختصار بين الموقفين لكن
اولا ايران دائما كانت وما زالت مستعده
للتفاوض حول خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه
ولم تضف اي شرط مطلقا وانما رفضت الشروط
الامريكيه التي اضافتها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه خارج اطار الاتفاقيه او خطه
العمل المشترك النقطه الثانيه المناولات
العسكريه التي اشار اليها ضيفك الكريم من
امريكا بين اسرائيل بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه فيها خير دليل على التنسيق
العسكري بين الطرفين وما قلته سابقا ان
هذه الحمل لا يمكن ان تكون الا بضوء
الاخضر من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لماذا تاتي بعد هذه المناورات التي تفضل
الضيف لانها كانت اضخم او اكبر مناوله اما
بالنسبه للسلاح النووي ايران لا تريد
انتاج السلاح النووي مطلقا ولا تتجه نحو
ذلك لكن دائما تؤكد حقها في امتلاك
المشروع النووي السلمي وزياده التخصيب نعم
هذا حسن هذا حصل بسبب السياسه الامريكيه
الخاطئه التي كانت تتصور انها بهذه الضغوط
يمكن ان تثني ايران عن مشروعها لكن
النتيجه كانت ان ايران رفعت مستوى التخصيب
اذا ارادت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
تستمر في هذه الضغوط وفي سوء التقدير لها
لماذا تاثير هذه الضغوط ولماذا يعني
استعداد ايران لان تركع امامها هذه الضغوط
فاقول انها خاطئه لان ذلك يقوي الموقف
الايراني
حكم من احكام القانون الدولي تحدد نسبه
التخصيب في ايران
خطه العمل المشتركه
سيد جاسم ذكرنا الروسيا هل هناك فرز دولي
واصطفاف دولي الان في ما يخص الملف النووي
وغيره من الامور
والى اين يمكن ان يتجه كل هذا
همم
اتفاق بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ودول الاوروبيه المملكه المتحده المانيا
وفرنسا بضروره بدعم الاتفاق التي تم
التفاوض بشانه لاحياء خطه العمل الشامله
المشتركه في شهر ايلول سبتمبر الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والدول الاوروبيه خاب
ظنها لان ايران لم تقبل بالاتفاق المقترح
اعتقد ان كل الدول الغربيه تحدد فكره
العوده الى اتفاق مع ايران بشان الموضوع
النووي بالرغم من الاعتراض الكبير في
اوروبا على مستوى الدول الاوروبيه بشان
تقديم ايران الاسلحه
لروسيا وايضا بنسبه الى افعال الحكومه
الايرانيه لقمع المظاهرات في ايران بالرغم
من هذه المجالات الجديده التي تؤدي الى
التوتر بين ايران والدول الاوروبيه اعتقد
انه اذا ما قررت ايران ان تقبل المقترح
الذي تم التقدم به في ايلول سبتمبر
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والدول
الاوروبيه سوف تكون على استعدادا للمضي
قدما لاعاده احياء الاتفاق شكرا جزيلا لكم
من مدينه كامبرد في ولايه ماسه سوسه
الدكتور جاريسي
منسق السابق في اداره اوباما لشؤون مكافحه
الارهاب وكان معنا من طهران محمد مهدي
شريعه مداري الدبلوماسيه الايراني
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لكم والي اللقاء
[موسيقى]